il représente tout je considère comme un
bien de famille
je me tuerai plus d'ailleurs j'ai pas
dit tuer pendant la guerre en le
défendant avec les Allemands
la Bretagne une côte d'échiquetée que la
mer à la sablement lèche de ses vagues
tantôt non chalantes tantôt une côte qui
serait meurtrière pour le navigateur si
de nombreux fans ne le guidaient dans la
nuit
c'est dans un de ces phares que nous
nous sommes rendus
nous y avons rencontré mademoiselle le
bail qui depuis 38 ans allume le phare
du crash
exactement pour le 2 novembre
j'ai été nommée le 2 novembre 1925 en
remplacement de masseur je vais perdre
la troisième génération de famille ah
oui c'est mon grand-père qui l'a allumé
le premier en 1855 après vous avez connu
alors le temps de l'allumage au lance de
la pétrole ah oui parce que j'ai marché
au pétrole c'est-à-dire le phare a
marché au pétrole de
1952 moi j'ai fait de 1925 à 52 avec le
pétrole et comment était le service
était dur à l'époque il fallait faire
des rondes de nuit par tous les temps
par tous les temps alors que j'ai
environ 700 mètres à faire de la maison
ici c'était pas toujours agréable j'ai
souvent reçu les embrasses sur le nez
comme il y avait du mauvais temps et
maintenant tout marche avec piscine
surtout que nous avons des batteries
d'accus alors un pas de panne ça se
déclenche automatiquement c'est vrai que
est-ce que vous vous levez la nuit pour
voir si le pharmacien
juste une petite visite mais quand vous
êtes malade imaginez jamais été malade
pour m'empêcher de faire mon service et
pendant les vacances
j'ai un mois de congé payé je vais
passer 8 jours chez mes neveux à
Saint-Nazaire et je me dépêche de
revenir vite à Montfort que j'aime
beaucoup
il me manque et vous êtes marié ah non
je suis célibataire
les journées ne sont pas trop longues en
été ça passe très vite mais en hiver
vraiment c'est là
parce que les femmes
je fais un peu de nettoyage et
je m'occupe un peu de street culture
mais je fais sans petite quantité juste
pour m'aider à vivre parce que mon
traitement n'est pas toujours suffisant
il est de combien
en ce moment
190 180 francs par mois pour ça j'ai mon
logement mon électricité
chaque journée commence dans la cuisine
ou des photos de famille que vous venez
de voir
un chat
un poste de radio un chien comble la
solitude mademoiselle le bail
aussitôt après avoir pris son petit
déjeuner elle part elle prend
aujourd'hui sa voiture pour se rendre à
Saint-Philibert dont elle est
conseillère municipale
mais au passage elle s'arrête pour
l'entretien de son phare
tâches qui chaque matin passe avant tout
autre activité
et c'est avec tendresse que l'on enlève
les moindres traces de poussière pour
qu'il conserve tout son éclat
de retour chez elle elle fait un peu de
jardinage
et avant de repartir car dans la journée
elle ne fait que de très rares
apparitions chez elle mademoiselle le
bail fait retentit une clochette pour
annoncer vos poules que leur repas est
servi
puis revêtu d'un pantalon pour conduire
sa camionnette elle part consacrer
quelques heures à la culture des naissa
avant qu'il ne le fasse personne dans le
village n'osait s'aventurer sur la plage
au volant d'une voiture de peur de son
lycée maintenant tous les ostréiculteurs
le font
mais revenons aux phares que représente
ce phare pour vous
il représente tout je ne considère comme
un bien de famille
je me tuerai plus d'ailleurs j'ai failli
tuer pendant la guerre en le défendant
avec les Allemands
quand je ne pourrai plus je voudrais que
ce soit mon neveu qui me remplace
mais je crois que vous avez tout
particulièrement voulu faire ce travail
parce que je suis né à édique et là-bas
j'ai vu un naufrage et ça m'a toujours
donné l'idée de gardienne de phare pour
allumer les feux pour que les mains
évitent les écueils mais dites moi
est-ce que il y a une grosse différence
entre les phares d'antan et les phares
d'aujourd'hui il y a pas de comparaison
monsieur avant ça marchait au pétrole
les appareils un peu défectueux ça
s'éteignait il fallait venir la nuit
finalement on m'a changé on m'a mis des
lampes à la fin que tu es la fin les
lambada en appartement très très bien
mais là où il y a un taux de courant
d'air il y a rien à faire ça fume comme
des chaudrons et puis je crois que c'est
là que vous avez pris une mauvaise manie
j'ai pris l'habitude de fumer vous fumez
beaucoup
par jour en effet mais
c'est à cause de ces fameuses en papier
trolls qui fumaient elles aussi qui me
faisait veiller toute la nuit parce que
les précédentes je faisais des rondes
deux fois par nuit mais je pouvais les
faire de chez vous est-ce que j'étais
obligé de venir ici et il y a 700 mètres
du phare chez moi en effet mais
dites-moi est-ce que vous avez d'autres
occupations maintenant que avec
l'électricité c'est quand même plus
simple
et puis vous êtes conseiller municipal
l'élevage de naissance et vous êtes
conseiller municipal aussi
je suis conseiller municipal depuis
1944 vous êtes toujours
est-ce que vous cesserez un jour le
gardiennage de ce phare oui je crois que
je dois cesser l'année prochaine à 75 et
là dites-vous et là j'espère que mon
neveu va me
remplacera et on me laisse un petit
logement ça va être le jeune quitterai
pas le force ça me changera pas beaucoup
et que ferez-vous je continuerai un peu
de ce structure tant que pourri c'est
vous-même qui vous servez de votre
barque je crois il paraît que vous
ramenez fort bien c'est moi qui godille
qui envoie mes embarcations sur les
parcs
et j'aime ça
[Musique]